hey everybody um my name is carter
robasa and i'm a developer evangelist
for a company called twilio we're based
in san francisco the company is based in
san francisco but actually uh i hail
from seattle so i'm incredibly happy to
be here amongst the sun and the warmth
of florida
and i'm here to talk to you about a
subject that is a very near and dear to
my heart
and that is
what are we as a community gonna do
to make more people around the world
interested in programming
um
you know i uh i come at this from
a very uh
you know unique perspective not unique
i come from it from my own perspective
you know i'm a father
i think a lot of people who
sort of understand uh the lack of desire
to program and are working to combat it
you know come at this from lots of
different perspectives you know some of
them are educators um you know lots of
people have reasons um to care about
this issue um but i care about it
because i'm a dad
um
uh i have two beautiful daughters um the
first one is catherine
uh catherine is three and a half years
old um this photo was taken one year ago
at js conf in scottsdale
um and she may look like she's coding
but she really isn't uh i just it was
more of a photo op um but a funny story
about uh about kids and conferences so
pet conferences have tons of stickers
don't they
claim they're everywhere you know who
likes stickers
so um so by the way who here was at js
comp last year
awesome so you know if catherine
wandered up to you and stole stickers
from you know i apologize but it's
totally not her fault it's just how they
are
my other daughter is emily
this is her
she's going to be two in august
and uh my wife is amazing
my wife knows that i'm a developer and
i'm a nerd and all developers love
mustaches for some reason
so she bought emily this uh this
mustache onesie which
is why i'm
choosing this particular picture to show
you guys um but but the point is you
know
i have recently become interested in
this issue of people not getting into
coding and because i'm a father and i
intensely think about the future much
more than i used to
and i think about their future and i
think about what they might what they
might do or what they might want to do
or what they might think that they're
actually capable of doing um and you
know i'm a technical person and their
mother is a technical person and
actually you know i think about you know
whether they will be technical people or
they'll get into the technology industry
and if even if they want to like what
kind of barriers might they face
i also have two daughters
and me and my wife are not going to be
having any more children so i now am
acutely aware of the gender issues you
know in our industry and i'm intensely
concerned about them um and in some ways
i sometimes i feel like i'm throwing my
hands up because you know i see a lot of
people doing a lot of good things trying
to address this but the numbers sort of
speak for themselves
so um and we'll get into that a little
bit later so uh
i look i look at the world that we live
in
and i feel like this is this is a bit of
a
name you know i apologize if it feels
played out but you know software is
meeting the world uh that is a that's
the title of an article written by a guy
named mark andreessen um he published it
in the wall street journal a couple of
years ago
and it was
pretty much a treatise on the fact that
every single industry in the world
is being devoured by software or
software companies
um and you don't have to look far to see
a phenomenon right you know i was just
watching madman with my life
last night or on sunday night you know
well guess who the biggest advertising
company in the world is you know it's a
soccer company it's google
um you know look at uh you know who do
you think the largest retailer in the
world is amazon
um you know i don't want to get caught
up on you know who's number one who's
number two you know maybe there's some
retailer that's slightly bigger than
amazon my revenue right now but i have
every confidence that's going to change
netflix is a great example they're
streaming more video than anybody else
um and maybe they're not technically as
big as some of the larger some of the
larger media conglomerates today but i
believe they will be
you know pixar pixar is both critically
acclaimed
and one of the most profitable movie in
movie studios in the world
and they're a software company and there
are obviously people that work at pixar
that are not developers but everyone in
that company is a software person they
think about how they can use software to
create experiences for people
um
and you know the list of industries
that's being disrupted today uh you know
goes on and on and on now you might say
carter you know that's uh
that's not true for all industries you
know there are plenty of industries that
are resistant to this disruption um you
know whatever your pet industry might be
or your friend's pet industry and i'm
just i just believe that you're wrong um
you know you can look at the automobile
industry right
you may say to yourself hey that's not
fair tesla's not a software company they
just make really sick amazing
electric vehicles
they're very expensive and they're very
well designed and that people love
and
you don't have to listen to me you can
you can listen to elon right i mean if
you talk to you read interviews vlogmas
they'll tell you
that the kind of people the tesla hires
are software people they're the kind of
people who think that software can
enhance
um
experiences for people
when you look at how the roadster and
the model s are designed they're massive
computing machines they collect
gigabytes and terabytes of data send it
back to tesla and tesla uses that data
to improve the software for the cars in
almost real time and over longer
stretches of time uses all that data to
produce better designs
so you know and who is elon musk well
guess what i mean he's he founded paypal
you know he's a software person he's
just applying what he knows in the
software field to other industries and
this is a pattern you know that you're
going to see over and over again in
other industries
this is the um this is the ceo of the
company i work for
jeff lawson
twilio is trying to disrupt the telecom
industry i'm sorry i'm using a word
disrupt it's a crappy word i should have
thought of a better one um but
what he's really trying to do is he's
trying to empower software people to
build amazing experiences for people
you know on top of the telecom
infrastructure
um you know think about
the worst phone you've ever used at some
company you work for
um or god forbid a pay phone or like if
you're as old as me like you remember
these horrific
experiences trying to dial extensions
and get routed and be connected and like
those are experiences that are designed
and built and delivered by hardware
people
um
is trying to enable software people to
build much more elegant user-friendly
experiences and that's incredibly
important um and you see this you know
not just in telecom like you know you
see this with things as simple as a
remote control you look at a cable or a
television remote control it's
disgusting
um but it's a byproduct of engineers of
hardware engineers and how they think
about user interface and solving
problems look at the apple remote it's
beautiful it's elegant you know it's
multifunctional you can do lots of
things with it
um
my wife and i we recently bought a house
and one of the first purchases i made
was a nest
you know like why
you know i don't i don't know why right
i mean on some level i thought that the
thermostat that was there was just ugly
it was right in my dining room right
where i'm going to be entertaining
people it's just this ugly disgusting
thing but also i couldn't i didn't know
i didn't understand how to use it it was
unapproachable to me and then you know
ness came along and created something
better and they didn't create something
better accidentally they created
something better because they're
software people and they implied how
they think about software to the problem
of you know thermostats and you're
seeing this over and over again
so if you believe what i've said so far
there's this consequence
and this is another
cliche
that i happen to believe is true you
know programming is
literacy maybe it's not literacy today
but it's going to be literacy by the
time you know my daughters are older
um
people take literacy for granted i think
people in the u.s take literacy for
granted i think they're people who work
for nonprofits and people who are
exposed to other parts of the world that
do not take literacy for granted and
understand how critical literacy is
to lifting people out of poverty
in 1440 when gutenberg invented the
printing press
only 30 percent of continental europe
was literate and you know now today the
the number is probably in the you know
not you know like you know you know 99
or something like that right
and literacy isn't just an abstract
thing right literacy directly translates
to better health
greater social equality
and increased uh economic prosperity
so if that's what literacy is
and you believe that
programming knowing how to code is
becoming a form of literacy then you
should have pause
um for you know for the state of the
world today and and where we're going
um
here's another fact that i find to be
incredibly disturbing
young people are not embracing
programming now this is the freakiest
thing of them all right because anybody
can look at a demographic trend and kind
of plot out into the future that's easy
i graduated from high school in 1996. in
the mid 90s if you thought programming
was stupid or you thought email was
stupid that was totally okay like that
was a rational
understandable you know opinion to have
about technology at that point
um
because email was esoteric and the web
was brand new and you could be forgiven
for thinking that you could spend your
whole life and never have to touch email
however the fact that today
the fact that it's 2013
and people still sort of feel this way
about technology and about being able to
wield technology is unbelievably
frightening
i mean look at these numbers you know
like you could other than some blips you
know enrollment in computer science is
first of all pathetic but also fairly
flat right i mean there's mild growth
but nowhere near the kind of growth you
would expect same with engineering um
like how is this possible right how is
it possible that intelligent pragmatic
you know educated young people can look
at the world that they live in and the
world that they're likely to live in and
completely reject learning how to
program or learning anything about how
to wield a computer i mean i find this
like baffling and astonishing and scary
and then of course you know the gender
inequality is you know is is dramatic as
well so so the question is you know
what's happening
and i don't have answers you know i'm
trust me there are people who spend more
time thinking about this than me
i'm here to say
that
we all need to work on fixing this you
know there's
you know there are incredibly smart
people like john resig you know working
at khan academy trying to sort of
reinvent education
think god bless them thank god um but i
think the problem is more pervasive than
that i think every single person in this
room can help
can help address this problem
um and not and more so i want and i want
to say something stronger right we have
a moral imperative to solve this problem
you know this problem is no different
than
women suffer i mean you know i i hate to
draw direct comparisons
um but you know to me
it is
in the same ballpark as women suffrage
and other social issues that people had
to deal with in the past
because of the
the fact that being literate translates
into how the quality of the life that
you can live
um
this is a reginald uh braithwaite um i
had to look up his name uh i know him as
ragenwald um on hackernews he's just a
prolific writer
and you know he wrote a blog post
recently called calling all hackers
and
he
you know he he sees the world that i see
right he sees a world where
you know there's a massive amount of
sort of cultural exclusion of outsiders
in the technology industry
and he wonders why this is the case
um and what we need to do to fix this
he sees a very uneven application of
programming
in the world right so think of all the
places you could apply programming and
software and it's very lumpy right
and this is incredibly problematic um
and essentially uh he he he wrote a blog
post where he was calling out to hackers
and why was he doing that well hackers
hackers changed the world um you know
and the way they change the world is
that they wrap around damage right they
see things that are broken and they try
to fix them it's a it's just something
that's inside of a person if you if you
think of yourself as a hacker you're the
kind of problem that wants you're the
kind of person that wants to solve
problems and wants to fix things and
wants to make the world better and he
sort of put out this uh you know this
sort of um you know this message um
asking people to to really dive in
um
who here knows who brett victor is
a few of you i watched the video
three weeks ago
that was unbelievable um it's called
inventing on principle
and
it informed his talk quite quite a bit
uh brent victor is a guy he's worked
lots of places um and he did a lot of
innovative ui work at apple um and he
there's this hour-long video on the
internet called inventing on principle
where he's giving a talk much better
than this talk by the way um where
and you know and i have an appendix of
links and you guys should go check it
out where basically he
says it is morally wrong for people who
build tools and technology and platforms
to build them in such a poor way that
ideas are allowed to die
um
what he's trying to say is that we are
we are all creative we are all creators
in some some sense of that word right we
know a programmer is no different than a
sculptor or a painter or a writer
someone who creates something and
there's this human need
for creators to have an immediate
connection to like what they're creating
so like a painter every stroke they're
seeing they're getting feedback like
real-time feedback on what they're doing
same with a sculptor sculptor same with
a writer and brett looked at the world
of being a programmer and you know
looked at the sort of the process of
writing code in an ide and then
compiling that code and then maybe
deploying that code to a device and then
running the code
and in some cases the delta is massive
right and you don't find out until five
minutes later that something's wrong or
that you know or that you did something
wrong and that that breaks things for
for programmers that are are a uh
flawless never make mistakes um or be
incredibly patient it's not a problem
because if you don't make mistakes you
won't make any mistakes and if you're
incredibly patient you don't care you'll
just wait the problem is that most of
the world is not like that most of the
world when you look at um when you when
you look at the the dropout rates in
computer science and engineering these
people are at least initially interested
in these fields but then they drop out
they quit
and why do they quit well there's lots
of reasons but i think that the state of
tooling today is part of the reason that
people quit they try to do something and
they don't get immediate feedback
on on what they're doing or the result
of what they're doing and it essentially
causes them to give up on it and then
their idea dies right and that is that's
wrong
because that person could have an idea
that changes the world
but it died because we didn't give them
good enough tools to use
so
i think i mentioned that i don't have
you know a definitive solution for this
i don't think anybody does
um
but i have i have this thought that um
that better apis can help right that
better apis
can be a part
of this larger story better tooling can
help there's lots of things that can
help i happen to spend a lot of time
thinking about apis so i'm sort of
approaching this problem from somewhat
of a specific perspective
so the question so first question you
know like what is an api and i'm not
trying to devolve into that argument you
can the truth is actually everyone has
their own specific definition of what an
api is and people argue about it and
it's like you know i hate these
arguments
i think we all know what a language is
you know we're all presumably javascript
developers you know we understand that
languages have syntax and semantics and
have a grammar
and to me like an api is just anything
on top of that
um sort of a well-defined interface to
enabling somebody to do something that
they want to do
above and beyond the language itself
um
helps you solve problems you know so
let's say we're on a web page and we
want to find the boxes that are checked
on a web page right well there's this
awesome api called the javascript dom
api
just kidding it's not awesome at all it
sucks
um
and that's what the code looks like
all right that's gross right
now it works
and it's logical you know you can kind
of look at it but that's an insane
num amount of code to write to do
something relatively basic
it's also error-prone right because even
if you know javascript
like did you know
that you can't use for each to iterate
through a node list
i mean maybe you know that from
experience like from the terrible
experience of trying and having it fail
but this is just it's just not a good
api it's not good api design
um
you know contrast that to the jquery api
look i'm not i'm not trying to sell
jquery right a lot of people are moving
away from jquery and for totally valid
reasons but that has nothing to do with
the design of its api it just has has to
do with the kind of problems that people
are trying to solve
you know this is what it takes to do
this in jquery
once again i don't find it surprising at
all that john resig is tackling
education
i think
if you find an api in the world that you
find to be elegant and easy and
understandable and pleasant to use the
person who designed it
probably cares about your your
experience using it and probably cares
about education and probably wishes that
more people would use that api
so then there are web apis
you know we all we all know what web
apis are we're all familiar with them
this is this is roy fielding
so roy fielding wrote an incredibly
famous dissertation on uh on rest on
rest
and
that work spawned
a multitude of companies like twilio and
many many others that provide these
restful web apis
and these are
these apis are amazing they're amazing
for lots of reasons and i'm not going to
go into all of them
but you know they they took something i
actually come from an era kind of prior
you know prior to the the onslaught of
restful apis i come i i remember soap
does anyone here remember soap
okay oh my god yeah like shocker that
soap didn't catch on right but there's a
there's a reason it didn't catch on it
wasn't accessible it wasn't
understandable it was monolithic it had
all these terrible characteristics um
that the big companies didn't care about
because they didn't care about the
pervasiveness of soap services you know
they cared about solving their
particular problems and charging you
like a ton of money um you know for the
privilege of of having that of having
those problems solved um so i'm not
surprised so there's no surprise that
soap failed it wasn't democratic you
know wrestle apis are very democratic
you know even a novice developer can
understand and interact with with a
restful api
um the twilio api is is an example of
this so you know we like to say twilio
you know if you're if you're a web
developer
you're automatically a twilio developer
and there's a there's i mean part of
that is marketing but part of that is
true
um
you know this is this is some node
some node code uh to send an sms
um
it's it's i mean you know i i proved
it in reality that's like two lines of
code to send an sms i was in vancouver
and i was sitting next to some kids uh
some sophomores in college that had
never heard of twilio i pulled out my my
computer and i just asked them hey
what's your cell phone number man and i
sent them an sms right in front of them
and i couldn't believe i mean i can
believe it now right but i mean if you
really think about like they were blown
away like i might as well have like
started walking on the ceiling as far as
they were concerned because they simply
they did not grasp that that was
something that they were capable of
doing
um and i think that's true for for way
more people than we realize
um
process that's an example of sending an
sms out processing an sms so twilio
makes makes use of web hooks um which
means that every time an sms comes into
twilio we send a post request to your
web application and your web application
returns with markup
um in this case as web developers you're
all familiar with markup like you're
familiar with html um the only
difference is with twilio you just you
generate some xml but you're still
generating markup every single tool that
you use to generate markup every part of
your tool chain you can still use it you
just need to generate a little bit of
xml
so
this is where you know we kind of come
to the end of this talk and
i honestly believe that every single
person sitting here
can help
solve this problem right can at least
take a small step towards solving this
problem you do not have to be the chief
architect
for some
you know restful api company in order to
like make the world a better in order to
create better apis and make the world a
better and more accessible for place for
people trying to get into programming
you know like first of all think about
think about the industry that you work
in right like i don't care what it is
like
try to make the world try to make more
of the world more of the surface area of
the world addressable to programming
you know jeff says uh you know
if you can if you can turn a problem
into a software problem like you can
solve it right if you can find a way to
like make more things that you work on
addressable to programmers you know
you're going to be able to harness you
know
all the programs in the world to sort of
solve some of the problems that are in
your industry
improve the accessibility of your apis
like and i'm talking every api right
like if look if you write a function
or method and that function is going to
be called by someone on your team or
someone in your group or someone at your
company
or someone outside of your company like
literally if you're defining a method
signature like think really hard about
it
think
ten times as hard about it as you
normally do just as an experiment
um you know i i you know i i've started
doing this myself right like i have a
ton of crappy code out there and i used
to think it didn't matter because it was
just my problem you know that's not true
you know like the with more more and
more people looking at code on github
you know people are learning like how to
code from you know code snippets that
you would never think that they would
look at and if they're bad code snippets
or they're poorly documented or they
don't make sense or they don't provide
instant feedback then they may get
disturbed discouraged and maybe decide
you know screw this i don't want to do
this
this is a crazy esoteric field for you
know masochists and that's that's
terrible right so you know i think um i
think we all have a role to play here
and lastly
please
commit yourself
to helping more people learn how to code
um
at twilio
every single person who joins the
company no matter what role they have
has to write an application their first
week on the job
that's sales people
marketers customer service
administrative support it doesn't matter
who you are like you have to write an
application and that's and you might
think that's really daunting and like
holy crap like that's unfair but it
actually isn't because everyone at the
company is part of our culture and
everyone at the company rallies to help
that person
define what it is they want to try to do
and help teach them how to do it
like
more companies should do stuff like this
and it also doesn't have to be a company
thing like find someone in your life
that is curious about programming and
expose them to it and talk to them about
it and learn from them what is so
inaccessible and so daunting about it
and see what we can do to you know to
kind of help make a help make the world
a better place so
um
that's it thank you very much
you